Joe Biden's doj has just announced that
it will continue to investigate and
likely prosecute Biden's Chief political
rival in 2024 Donald Trump and in
classic leftist Newspeak Biden's
attorney general Merrick Garland framed
the announcement as evidence that the
investigation and likely prosecution
would not be political because the doj
would hire a special counsel now the
purpose of a special counsel is to avoid
conflicts of interest in prosecutions in
the case of this investigation the
investigation of a former president
currently running for president against
the guy who took his job we have never
seen anything like it before so the
standard should be much much higher to
avoid the appearance of any sort of bias
the standard should be much higher that
Biden isn't just going to throw
everything he's got at Trump to stop him
from running against him in 2024. so
what did Biden do
he appointed Jack Smith an Obama hack
lawyer who most recently prosecuted war
crimes at the Hague so looking like
Biden is going to go with the scorched
Earth strategy kill the campaign in the
Cradle approach to Trump's campaign
because if you don't think that you can
beat your opponent fair and square your
only chance at keeping power is to rig
the system against him I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from Mike Hoff who
says Beto listening to Michael say
there's no such thing as a lost cause so
you're saying there's a chance yeah
that's that is what beta was saying
right now I assume he's going to be
running for dog catcher in some poor
poor locality sometime in 2024 and I
hope that locality protects itself I
hope you protect yourself in your home
it's why you need ring with the holidays
coming around the corner many of us will
be traveling to see our families and
loved ones soon you may find yourself
away from home more often than not that
is why I have decided to team up with a
ring with ring security products you can
rest easy knowing that your home and
family are safe when you are not there
the ring doorbell notifies you when
guests or packages arrive Rings indoor
cameras let you keep an eye on kids and
pets while you're away ring alarm will
alert you of any motion detection while
the house is empty plus if you add smart
lighting around your home you can turn
lights on or off while you're away
Ring's home security products don't just
help keep your home and family safe they
make perfect gifts for everyone on your
list head on over to ring.com
collections slash offers to find out how
you can live stress free this season
with a ring product that is right for
you that is ring.com collections slash
offers do it right now make sure that
you protect your home when you're going
to your relatives for Thanksgiving when
you're going to Grandma's house for
Christmas Eve head on over ring.com
collections slash offers if the
Democrats truly believed that they could
easily defeat Trump at The Ballot Box in
2024
they would not be investigating and very
likely Prosecuting him
it's a way that's the way it is
notice you didn't really hear or talk
about an investigation and a prosecution
from the doj of Donald Trump until it
started to look more and more like Trump
was going to run in 2024. then all of a
sudden there was one day in the Summer
where it looked like Trump was going to
announce and he had been suggesting that
he would that he would make a big
announcement on that day on Truth social
throughout social media and what happens
that was the day that Biden's FBI thugs
kicked down the door at Mar-A-Lago and
and raided the former president's home
so obviously this is nakedly political
and then the the Biden doj to pretend
that it's not political what do they do
they appoint a war crimes prosecutor to
go after Biden's Chief rival it's just
so transparent and it's it's clear
enough to me that the Democrats believe
that if they don't rig the system in
2024 that Trump will beat them and
that's probably wise for them to think
that because you hear a lot of talk of
oh Donald Trump he's the only Republican
who could lose in 2024. you hear this
from the Democrats you hear this from
the Republicans oh those Republicans
they need to pick somebody better
because Trump he's sure to lose he's
sure okay if he's so sure to lose then
why are the Democrats doing every single
thing they can to keep him off the
ballot if he's so sure to lose why did
the Democrats keep testing out ways to
argue that the 14th Amendment stops
people who led an Insurrection from
getting on the ballot they tried that
against Marge retailer green they tried
that against other members of Congress
it was obviously a test run to keep
Trump off the ballot you hear left-wing
commentators on on MSNBC and elsewhere
say that well Donald Trump he's
ineligible to run for president okay if
you think he's going to be so easy to
beat then why are you trying to keep him
off the ballot because you know
that you all were wrong when you said
that in 2016 and he beat you in 2016 and
he's a hell of a lot stronger than
everyone is pretending right now and so
you think that if you kill the campaign
in the Cradle that's going to give you a
much better shot than you'll go up
against a more standard Republican and
the Democrats believe they can they can
beat that Republican maybe not even
because the Republican is weak maybe
just because they've already so
thoroughly rigged the elections that it
will be much easier and when I say
rigged the elections what am I talking
about I'm talking about extend voter day
to voter month I'm talking about push
widespread mail-in ballots in some cases
unconstitutionally or illegally I'm
talking about ballot harvesting I'm
talking about no voter ID I'm talking
about all the things that the Democrats
have pushed for decades and really
really ramped up during the covid-19
lockdowns they used covet as the excuse
to change all the election rules to rig
it against the Republicans and and for
some reason those rules are still in
place that's how you know that it was
totaled BS in 2020 because if the
argument was in 2020 we need to change
all the voter rules and get rid of all
the the election Integrity measures
because of this worldwide pandemic that
we've never seen anything like it so
we've got to change all the rules if
that were the case then why were those
rules still in place
in democrat-controlled areas in 2022
covet is over Joe Biden admitted the
pandemic is over so then why do you
still have the widespread mail-ins why
do you still have election season why do
you still not have voter ID requirements
why because the Democrats obviously want
to rig it I know we're not allowed to
talk about that but I'm going to talk
about it anyway listen Elon Musk bought
Twitter social media feels Freer so I'm
going to speak as bluntly as I possibly
can there are a whole lot of
pieces of evidence that there was fraud
in Arizona in 2022 there's a lot more
evidence that there was fraud in 2020
but even just this last election even in
the midterms right now there is a
fabulous website who'scounting.us
slash Maricopa you can see Maricopa
election workers recounting in first
person testimony the kind of shenanigans
that the the clear evidence I think of
fraud from the midterm elections
my name is Sarah O'Neill I've been an
Arizona resident for the past three
years I was a poll Watcher for both the
primaries primaries and the midterms and
I wanted to relay my observations with
no commentary or accusation
the door number three debacle when I
checked in I was the afternoon and
evening and closing pole Watcher I did
confirm that our tabulators were cleared
they were all zeros but I also did
confirm that there was no instruction
for inspecting to ensure the door three
or the slot 3 was empty so no one in not
a poll worker not a poll Watcher
inspected to make sure it was empty and
the reason that's the point is at the
end of the day we were asked to report
the number of Voters checked in the
number of ballots that we're
transporting and of those number of
ballots how many were door number three
we had 1218 ballots we had only 1018
voters that checked in
and we had of those 1218 ballots 406
were door number three
so there you have it
if you don't remember the door number
three debacle what happened early in the
day in Maricopa County which is a
crucial County and a crucial swing state
that helped to swing the election
is that the voting machines stopped
working the voting machines reportedly
in disproportionately Republican
precincts stopped working and so people
had to to file their ballots
provisionally in what was called box
number three it was very convenient
there was this door number three this
was supposed to be a Fail-Safe measure
such that if the machine stopped working
don't worry you don't run your machine
through your ballot through the
tabulator you just put it in this box
and don't worry they'll count those
later and you you hear this poll
Watcher's testimony this woman sounds
totally normal doesn't sound like a
tinfoil hat lady she said I'm not going
to include commentary or accusations I'm
just going to tell you exactly what I
saw right I don't expect to see this
woman hosting a show on Infowars though
frankly Alex Jones has relatively a
pretty good record on getting stories
right but this woman doesn't sound like
someone who's about to rip her shirt off
and start screaming about the gay frogs
or anything she's just calling it like
she sees it and she says
at the end of the day
we counted the number of Voters who
checked in versus the number of ballots
we had
the number of ballots we had was 1218
the number of Voters we checked in was
1018 so you have this this really
perfect even number 200 extra ballots
and what do you know they happen to be
in box number three and why were they in
box number three because no one ever
checked to see if the boxes were stuffed
in the first place you check to see that
the boxes were cleared at the end of
election day but there was no measure in
place to check that the boxes were not
stuffed when the day started now this
has been a long-standing uh tool of
election theft and it goes back all the
way gosh it probably goes back to
ancient Athens which is stuffing The
Ballot Box but you see this especially
in the campaigns of Lyndon Johnson you
see this throughout the middle of the
20th century FDR and Lyndon Johnson
joked about this after FDR lost an
election and by the way he didn't lose
his next election for Senate
specifically because he stuffed The
Ballot Box which came out in the 1990s
and that number it's just such a strange
number exactly 200 extra ballots
compared to the number of Voters who
checked in
so what's that about it wasn't only this
woman who describes uh election
irregularities and the problem wasn't
only with box number three there were
other issues too
our rejection rate
um
which I confirmed with my Democrat poll
Watcher counterpart
I thought it was maybe 75 percent at
least he said oh no it's at least 90
percent rejection rate the 17
000 number that has been publicized as
door number three ballots is far
understated we were there we were there
the discrepancy and the number of
physical ballots that I had they came
from somewhere we had physically had
them they were not voters that walked in
and checked in we had 200 more ballots
than voters that checked in
and I just want that to be on the record
so she just wants this on the record she
says look the numbers just don't add up
here okay you don't need to be a math
whiz to know those numbers just don't
add up now who is running the elections
in Arizona it was the Secretary of State
Katie Hobbs who coincidentally was
running for governor that year but one
of the uh rebuttals to this observation
is well yeah sure Katie Hobbs was
technically in charge of the elections
but it was really the county level
people who were running it and by the
way in Maricopa County most of the board
members who were running the elections
most of them were Republicans so your
argument you crazy tinfoil hat Mega
people your argument is ridiculous and
that that would be a strong argument
that there wasn't an anti-republican
bias
if not for this one inconvenient fact
about the Republicans quote unquote who
were running the elections which we'll
get to in one second but first we want
to protect your elections you want to
protect yourself you need epic will
right now head on over to epicwill.com
use promo code Knowles if you are
listening to this show odds are that you
put a lot of stock into how you raise
your kids you understand that your
children look up to you to define the
way that they view the world and that is
why it is extremely important that you
have a will in place a will also
determines how your financial assets are
dispersed as well as your personal
property lays out your health care power
of attorney to ensure that your end of
life decisions are carried out if you
were just starting out and you don't
have thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you want to make sure your
savings your belongings your family are
all protected you got to create your
will at epicwill.com today
epic Will's early estate plans started
just 119 bucks you can save 10 when you
use promo code Knowles kwles go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that is
epicwill.com promo code Knowles protect
your stuff protect your wishes protect
your cute little kids protect it all
epicwill.com promo code Knowles so the
argument against the election fraud
claims in Arizona is it was mostly
Republicans running the show in Maricopa
okay who were the Republicans though and
what were their actual political views
and preferences here again at just open
testimony from the people who saw what
was going on in Maricopa here's the real
story
so chairman Bill Gates and recorder
richer you both have lost all
credibility in any shred of Integrity to
conduct free again we're not we're no
outbreak fair and transparent elections
here in Maricopa County when you both
opened in 2021 a political action
committee to specifically defeat Maga
candidates that actually was almost our
whole ballot for this primary from the
Republican party so if you think that
the public should believe the false
Narrative of well-run fair transparent
elections and outcomes that's you're
sorely mistaken that's not just a
conflict of interest it's a specific
agenda and a pre-bias going into it so
you at the very least you should have
recused yourself from any part of this
election having opened that in 2021
so these guys who were running the show
in Maricopa nominally they're
Republicans but they hate all the
Republican candidates it's like saying
that bill Crystal and David French are
Republicans they're not really
Republicans if ever they were
Republicans they certainly are no longer
they spend all of their time attacking
Republicans and Shilling for Democrats
it's like calling Liz Cheney a
republican yeah she still sort of keeps
an R by her name even though she was
booted out of her State's Republican
Party by vote but she's effectively all
she ever does is help the Democrats and
what This Woman's pointing out here is
she's saying look it's not even just
that you guys have your preferences
it's not even just that you registered a
certain way you have been actively
campaigning within the last year to
raise money for and help defeat all the
sort of Republican candidates that were
on this ballot you've taken
extraordinary political measures to do
that so at the very least you guys
should have backed away from running
this election especially an election
that from the get-go had so many
convenient and coincidental errors and
hold ups and snags and snafus and that
took days and days and days to tabulate
the results it's just BS okay and I
think this is one of the ways that you
can sniff out the difference between the
real right-wingers and the Court Jester
conservatives you know the real people
who who want to advocate for
conservative a conservative society and
the people who basically just exist to
legitimize the dominant liberal culture
okay who exists to do a little soft shoe
and a little dance routine to pretend
like there's opposition in our politics
when in fact there is not all they
really do is help to preserve the
legitimacy of the liberal order and and
one of the ways that that you can
distinguish between these two groups is
who is calling out the system
it's not just enough to attack those
socialist Democrats those socialist
Democrats want to raise your taxes can
you believe those that crazy AOC oh
goodness that crazy look what she said
now look she's a crazy leftist donate to
the Republican party because she's a
crazy yeah AOC is a problem yeah the
Socialists are a problem what about the
system
what about the system as far as I'm
concerned
in a post 2020 world after the Democrats
changed all the election rules to give
them an unfair advantage
after we saw a large portion of the
Republican Party outed as nothing more
than wolves and sheep's clothing doing
the bidding of the Democrats if you are
not talking about election integrity and
trying to fix that problem
then I think you're a fraud I think
you're a fraud conservative who doesn't
want to actually fix something if
all you are doing in politics is trying
to cut taxes and and look I love tax
cuts all right I'm not knocking tax cuts
I love it I don't want to pay any more
in taxes I want to pay much less but if
that's all you're talking about
and then if the effect of the rest of
your political views is to enshrine in
power the liberal order then I think
you're a fraud I'll give you an example
of this if you're one of these
Republicans who says well listen
I don't I don't like this big Tech
censorship but it's a private company
Google's a private company actually it's
not actually it was developed with fun
direct funding from the government but
and actually they have more power than
pretty much any nation in the history of
the world and they control our political
order and our our uh our speech regime
but anyway yeah sure they're a private
company and so therefore just build your
own Google if you're saying that you are
wittingly or unwittingly a shill for the
liberal order either way you're not a
real conservative as far as I'm
concerned if you're the sort of
conservative who says well
yeah it's probably not good
that we're flooding the country with a
million foreign Nationals legally every
year and 2 million foreign Nationals
illegally but you know
that's Freedom you know what the Statue
of Liberty is alleged to say you know uh
give us your poor huddled uh drug
dealing Mexican cartels and we'll give
you Freedom or something uh that's just
America you know if if the effect of
your political views your allegedly
conservative political views is to just
do everything the Liberals want censor
conservative speech flood the country
with illegal aliens Outsource jobs
give more medical power to a bunch of
weirdo bureaucrats like Dr fagi if
that's the
effect of your views then you're just a
fraud okay you're not calling out the
system at all you are you are a pawn in
the system and uh and I I absolutely
want nothing to do with those quote
unquote Republicans those quote unquote
conservatives okay now
speaking of the rigged system some
conservative politicians I'm thinking of
trump
I'm thinking of Victor Orban in Hungary
I'm thinking of Georgia Maloney in Italy
you know I love her
they're the kinds of politicians who run
and they don't just say the same old
platitudes they say no this is rigged I
know it's rigged I've seen it be rigged
Trump famously would say I know this
system is totally corrupt because I've
used it to my advantage yeah I used to
donate to Democrats because I greased
the wheels and I'd buy them off you're
right that's what happens in this in
this uh form of government so Georgia
Maloney just did this George Maloney
just put the rest of the EU specifically
France on blast on their ridiculous
Arguments for why they've got to flood
Europe with foreigners here's her
argument I'll Translate
these countries and it allows them to
take the exports
this is a child she's holding a picture
this is a child that works in a gold
mine in Burkina Faso it's one of the
poorest countries
the goal that this child goes down
mostly ends up in the French State
the solution here is not to take
Africans and bring them to Europe
solution is to liberate Africa from the
Europeans who are exploiting it and
allow these people to keep what they
have and live on what they have
beautiful beautiful stuff you can see
here not only a a good political end in
sight which is to stop the mass
migration to Europe which the European
people rightly don't like because it's
it's Lawless and it's unsustainable and
it will deprive them of their own
culture if you if you just flood a
country with new people and you don't
assimilate those people in any way which
is not it's not even possible the amount
of time that these people are coming in
then then you you destroy your own
culture and and so the way she's doing
it though
is she's making an argument that will be
that will be appealing to a broad array
of people she's not saying those awful
Africans we hate those Africans don't
let those Africans come in she's saying
the arguments that France is making are
Preposterous France is making the
argument that we need to take in all
these Africans and by the way the
Africans are mostly going to places like
Italy they're going to these first ports
of lampedusa and these kind of places
where they first come to and she says
but
you're making the argument that we need
to take these people in because their
countries are so poor but you France
you're looting those countries you're
exploiting those people and you are
profiting yourself and then you want
other people to pick up the tab and
that's so often what happens that's what
happens here with our woke corporations
our woke corporations will
will flood the country with illegal
aliens they will encourage it's not just
the Democrats encouraging illegal
immigration it's these corporations it's
it's the Chamber of Commerce too because
they know that it will give them cheap
labor
it'll reduce the costs of Labor and then
all the externalities all of the costs
that go along cultural
political Financial costs that go along
with illegal immigration crime
these companies say okay everyone else
has to deal with it it is just it it
really ends up being pretty simple
it is a consequence of turning politics
away from the common good of the whole
nation to provide for the general
welfare to think of us as a community as
United States of America
toward an entirely selfish view of
politics which we obviously see on the
left the left's new moral Maxim knew
it's been their moral Maxim now for 60
70 years is if it feels good do it if I
want to do it then I'm going to do it
you do you fine but but people on the
right have done this too this is the
rights adoption of greed is good there's
no such thing as the common good the
virtue of selfishness nonsense well it's
the left and the right both doing that
and what's the effect of it to rob the
country of of any sense of the common
good of any sense of commonality of any
sense that we're a country at all okay
but I am still an American I'm a
red-blooded American okay and my blood
is redder and more rich in iron because
I eat good ranchers right now head on
over to goodranchers.com use promo code
Knowles due to a shrinking herd beef
prices are expected to rise another 15
2023 prices are going to seem cheap in
just a few months Supply is going to
continue to become more and more scarce
that's why I love my good ranchers you
know what I had for lunch the other day
oh I was so excited I came in I'm
sitting down it was kind of a stir fry
and then some delicious steak on top I
said I tried the steak I said wow that
is some superb steak sweet little Elisa
where'd you get it and she said Mac that
steak and it was so good I think it was
the rib eye I forget but their quality
is just through the roof okay it's just
amazing
and what good ranchers does is they
inflation proof your grocery bill by
locking in your price for the life of
your subscription which is just
completely insane that you can choose a
price for meat right now and you're just
going to have it for your whole
subscription right now they've on top of
that have a great Black Friday offer get
two 12 ounce Black Angus near strip
steaks and two pasture-raised chicken
breasts for free with any order when you
use code Knolls head on over right now
goodranchers.com use code Knowles at
checkout for this special offer that's
goodranches.com code Knowles for two
Black Angus New York strip steaks and
pasteurized chicken breasts for free
with your order good ranchers American
Meat delivered
you talk about a rigged system
over the past two years at least so it's
really been building for a longer time
the social media Giants
have clamped down on conservative speech
it hasn't been an even clamping down on
speech it's been
almost entirely focused on the right
now what does that mean in a country
that's supposedly a self-government
where the way that we pass laws and
govern ourselves is by persuading one
another of arguments if you control
speech you control the whole culture
this is the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling wines
number one National bestseller it makes
a great Christmas present just pointing
that out before Black Friday so that has
been the situation on the ground and
then in walks
Elon Musk and Elon Musk comes in and he
buys Twitter and at first it seems like
a joke and a meme and for a while it
looked like he didn't want to buy
Twitter but then a judge sort of forced
him to buy Twitter and so anyway he
spends 44 billion dollars and he is
having a whole lot of fun and there have
been all of these debates over do you
let people on do you not let people on
do you have free speech do you not have
free speech I got into a little spat
with Sam Harris you know Sam Harris made
a splash as one of these
atheists 15 years ago he was one of the
four new atheists which was much more a
publishing Trend than a than an
intellectual movement but anyway that's
where he became somewhat famous and he
said it's really dangerous you can't
have people like Donald Trump or whoever
on Twitter it's really dangerous for
these people to spread misinformation
can you imagine how dangerous it is and
I and I responded to him and I said Sam
you know you're right
Elon should not tolerate the New York
Times or the Washington Post remaining
on this platform I mean that when I
think of the dangerous lies that they
spread those guys need to be axed
immediately and Sam responded with some
sort of glib you know oh yeah you've
really thought about this haven't you
Michael which by the way I have uh and
then I referenced my number one National
best-selling book speechless which I
recommend you get for Black Friday so
the the point here I think though is
that
the New York Times And The Washington
Post
are responsible for for a great deal
more evil because of their dishonest
journalism
than Donald Trump is
what do they accuse Donald Trump of
doing
Donald Trump LED an Insurrection he
didn't really do that well he led those
people to go to the Capitol well he sort
of a little bit he did that though he
said to be peaceful and people died yeah
the only person who died in the
political violence of that day was a
trump supporter named Ashley Babbitt who
was murdered by a trigger happy cop
that's it
and then I think if you really want to
add to the numbers you I think a couple
of people died of natural causes that
day there were a lot of people there and
people had heart attacks and stuff like
that but no one died no cops were
murdered none of that that was all
completely made up okay
furthermore when you look at the New
York Times as advocacy of certain Wars
you know you can look at the New York
Times spreading propaganda and nonsense
to justify some of our recent Wars the
thing about the people who died as a
result of that
you think about the the nonsense spread
by The Washington Post and the New York
Times with regard to the Russia hoax
which allowed or gave cover to the
government to spy on a rival
presidential campaign and then undermine
a duly elected president goodness sakes
that's a that's a big problem I mean I
was joking a little bit with Sam Harris
but I'm pretty serious there's a strong
argument to be made that the New York
Times And The Washington Post should not
be permitted on Twitter because their
their dishonesty has led to really awful
outcomes it's led to death in some cases
okay and so uh Elon Musk is taking a
middle ground here he is not a free
speech absolutist and he's getting a lot
of flack from the right about this but I
don't think he should I think this is
actually extremely based
I you know I
I know this puts me on the outs with
some of the right wing though I think
actually the conservatives are coming
much more over to my point of view here
but there's nothing conservative about
Free Speech absolutism
there's nothing conservative about
having a bunch of obscenity and porn and
direct threats all over social media and
in the Public Square that's not
conservative that's radical and leftist
okay and it was the libs Who tricked
conservatives into believing that
nonsense okay and so Elon Musk comes out
he says new Twitter policy is freedom of
speech but not freedom of reach negative
hate tweets will be Max debusted and
demonetized so no ads or other Revenue
to Twitter
you won't find the Tweet unless you
specifically seek it out which is no
different from the rest of the internet
Kathy Griffin Jordan Peterson and the
Babylon B have been reinstated Trump
decision has not been made yet although
you'll see what comes later
Alex Jones is not allowed on Twitter now
I don't agree with all of those
decisions I think Alex Jones should be
on Twitter Kathy Griffin I don't mind if
she's not on Twitter I'm glad that
eventually Trump did come back on
spoiler alert but
the principle that Elon is describing
here is totally right
okay and and you're hearing the right
say well new boss same as the old boss
this is no different from what the left
is doing
it is different it is different
when conservatives
allow good and true and beautiful things
to be
present in the Public Square and
discourage
ugly and false and evil things in the
Public Square
that is not the same
as when the left
exalts ugliness and wickedness and
falsehood
and suppresses goodness truth and Beauty
it's not the same yes both involve
having standards both involve having
Norms both involve having taboos both
involve limiting speech
but that procedural similarity does not
mean that they are substantively the
same thing
to do good and avoid evil is not the
same thing as to do evil and avoid good
okay and conservatives used to
understand this conservatives used to be
the group of norms and standards and
having higher ideals and being polite
and understanding chivalry chivalry is a
is a code of speech and behavior that
censors certain things okay being a
gentleman involves censoring certain
things and limiting what can be said and
done and promoting other things that are
said and done okay but
that's all regimes okay that's all
states that's all forms of speech there
are always limits and so I don't think
we should knock Elon for having
standards and Norms I think that
we should help to tweak his standards
and Norms but his standards and arms are
a hell of a lot better than Vijaya Gotti
was that her name the the Twitter
apparatchee who banned Trump the first
time and his and elon's are a hell of a
lot better than Jack dorsey's and I
think he should be encouraged in that
the lips are freaking out CBS news said
they were going to stop tweeting out of
an abundance of caution
caution about what well with the
changing standards at Twitter we're
going to stop tweeting out of an
abundance of caution what do you think
is going to happen
and then by the way this is the best
part 48 hours later CBS starts tweeting
again okay but we're monitoring the
situation they said but but we're going
to be back on Twitter okay that's great
if they're freaking out all right Trump
is back this and the way Elon did it was
brilliant he threw up a poll he said
should Trump go back on
most people said yes then all of a
sudden it started to turn there were
tens of millions of votes in this poll
you could tell there were some maybe
some political forces here that were
trying to keep Trump off of Twitter but
Elon said vox populi Vox day the voice
of the people is the voice of God
which is a principle I don't exactly
agree with but nevertheless it gave him
a way of bringing Trump back to Twitter
without taking all of the responsibility
for it's really important for the
political order when that
Twitter lawyer lady booted Trump off of
Twitter that was a revolution in
America's political order that was
saying that some billionaire leftists in
Silicon Valley and their Min their
minions can
sensor can ostracize the duly elected
sitting president of the United States
so it's a very important restoration of
America's political order this is not
just a minor funny little meme thing oh
there it goes Elon
he put Trump back this is actually a
major restoration of America's political
order the question is Will trump
actually come back on and use the
account
I hope he does when they restated
reinstated Trump's account he had zero
followers
now he's up to like 10 bazillion he's
got way more followers than Joe Biden
he's obviously very popular despite what
the lying press wants to tell you
despite the constant negative Fresco
FeFe is what Trump proved to us and I
think he should come back on the trouble
for Trump is he's he's made a deal with
truth social
that that will be his social media
platform but no one looks at truth
social the only reason anyone checks
truth social is to see what Trump has to
say which is probably a sizable number
of people but it's not actually being
used as a social network if Trump goes
back onto Twitter he will have so much
more reach he will dominate the
conversation again the guy is now a
declared candidate for president
so I hope he figures out some way to
thread the needle but I want Trump back
on Twitter good on Elon for doing it
good on Elon for having standards too
the guy is doing almost everything right
and the libs are so freaking out I don't
know about you I feel like I am living
in 2015 again I am having deja vu all
over again for some of our younger
listeners they might not even remember
2015 all that well I mean it's amazing
to think right now that's seven years
ago now it's a in within a month and a
half it's going to be eight years ago
that was a long time ago and it's it's
just makes me think that people
don't learn anything because all of the
same stupid arguments from all from
exactly the same people we are hearing
again Trot it out as though it is fresh
and new marks and angles you know talk
about calling out the system talking
about breaking up regular political
platitudes and attitudes I'll give marks
and Engels some credit here history
repeats itself first as tragedy then as
fars you know Jeremy's razors may have
started out as maybe the best joke we
ever told but now it is more real than
ever if you don't know the backstory
last year Harry's dropped their ads from
our Network condemning our views my
views in particular as inexcusable me
can you believe that me whom everybody
loves so uh because you know I said the
boys are boys and girls are girls now
rather than boycott Harry's uh daily
wire co-ceo on Dog King Jeremy boring
started his own rival razor company and
in his quest to earn your business from
those who woke companies that hate your
guts the god King has turned a single
yet glorious razor into a triumphant new
line of men's products products such as
a nourishing shampoo and conditioner
charcoal body wash luxurious beard kit
and a new Precision 5 razor with
flipback trimmer unlike those woke razor
companies Jeremy's is the only company
built on truth
like the truth that masculinity is not
toxic and that men cannot be women
so if you're ready to get a great shave
or exfoliating wash from a company that
refuses to play pretend or bow down to
the woke mob go to Jeremy's razors.com
today and remember stop giving your
money to woke corporations that hate you
give it to Jeremy instead
uh really tough news for Trump out of
the Huffington Post
oh it's the from The Huffington Post
quoting key Evangelical figures
there's the headline here
she Evangelical figures turn on Trump he
used us
Huffington Post says
one of these people ripped the
ex-president for acting like a little
Elementary School child another warned
that if the GOP turns to him in 2024 we
will get destroyed
we will Donald Trump can't save America
said one of these guys to The Washington
Post he can't even save himself
people are done with Trump
the walls are closing in they've got him
now
people
do these people ever learn anything no
they don't they don't
the reason that some people are
surprised by this is because they have
very short memories
I'm sure remember and so this is all
being reported as wow the Republican
party which was totally unified behind
Trump now some of them are turning on
him
Trump might not have that same lock on
the GOP that he previously had wow
certain Evangelical leaders are turning
on him allegedly wow certain
institutional establishment
conservatives are turning on him wow oh
gosh we've never seen this before this
was exactly what happened when he ran
this is the whole story of trump
he runs in 2015.
and you have
certain
leaders
of the of the conservative movement or
whatever you want to call it
say oh he's terrible he's awful if we
run with him we'll lose it's guaranteed
he's vulgar he is acts like a school
child it's even it's all the same
attacks
didn't matter then I don't think it will
really matter now
now I'm not saying necessarily that
Trump will get the nomination
but he has a good shot at it
he has a good shot at it because yes a
lot of conservatives a lot of people on
the right
don't like Donald Trump probably many
listeners to this show don't even like
Donald Trump you know I like him a lot
but
he's got I understand he's got flaws he
rubs people the wrong way maybe it's
just because I'm from New York that I
get a little more of a kick out of him
than other people do
but it doesn't matter he doesn't need to
win over the majority of Republicans
he doesn't
he needs to win over the plurality of
Republicans and and this is what and he
doesn't need to win over any of the
establishment Elite people who run the
media outlets and who run the think
tanks and who who even run the RNC that
doesn't matter okay he just needs a
plurality of the voters in the early
primary States
and so sure
you're going to have you just had
National Review just came out where are
they National Review says no
a firm unmistakable no from National
Review after he announces that he's
running
which doesn't carry any water anymore
because that's what they said last time
when he ran in 2015 they had a big front
page article against Trump and it was
all these different people who wrote
their own columns and Reflections on why
Trump shouldn't be the nominee and then
most of those people ended up supporting
Trump
no never a trump and then what happens
most of never Trump's ends up supporting
Trump so now you can't go back Paul Ryan
apparently just said he's never again
Trump you can't be never again Trump
never means never or you lose
credibility okay so so these guys they
come out and they say no we hate Trump
and then for two years they say no we
actually really like Trump four years we
really like Trump and now they hate
Trump again okay fine
but if we gave
any heed to what you were saying in 2015
we're not going to give heed to it now
because you're just blowing in the wind
back and forth and we know how it turned
out last time so why do we believe it's
going to turn down any differently
today I don't think necessarily that
Trump will get the nomination
but I think he's got a good shot at it
don't forget people forget they think
that Trump was inevitable in 2015. had
Marco Rubio dropped out of the race
earlier Ted Cruz would have been the
nominee would Ted have won the general I
don't know we we just can't know to
counter historical question but
it is it is in fact the case that Ted
Cruz would have gotten the nomination
had Rubio dropped out sooner that I
think we can say with some certainty so
a lot is going to depend now on the
candidates
in 2024
but Trump right now it right now the
whole thing looks and feels exactly like
it did in 2015. so we've got no reason
to think that Trump isn't going to have
a very good shot at it and the way the
libs and the way that the establishment
are freaking out over Trump right now
makes me think he's got a real good shot
over it okay the fact is
Trump remains extremely relevant Trump's
enemies
remain less relevant
fact is Mega the the movement that
supported Trump with a different set of
policy prescriptions than was being
offered by the GOP
remains relevant
the GOP establishment is much less
relevant certainly in the minds of
Voters and you hear people whining about
this I mean you hear Adam kinzinger you
know the male allegedly male Liz Cheney
comes out he goes on MSNBC and he whines
and he whines he says this isn't the GOP
this isn't this is tribalism it's all
the same rhetoric from seven years ago
why do you think more people don't feel
that he crossed their red lines in the
Republican party and you know part of
its tribalism right you know the second
if if one of them says look I've had
enough with Donald Trump you get kicked
out of your tribe look when I got
elected I remember I just gotten out of
Iraq this was 2009 I got elected in
2010. and I remember thinking if I'm
gonna ask people to be willing to die
for this country and obviously I'm gonna
have to take votes on that and I have I
have to be willing to give up my career
for the same cause now that sounds
Innovative but it's so true you know we
we swear an oath to the Constitution not
because what we're going to do is easy
and not because I have to take a poll
every time I vote on things like should
Donald Trump be impeached and what does
my district say it's because my oath is
not to my district
it's to the Constitution
and there he is Valiant Adam kinzinger
giving up his seat for the cause of our
democracy
and to fight that evil tribalism first
of all Adam kinzinger did not sacrifice
his seed for anything Noble his his
district was erased because of
redistricting in the state of Illinois
okay now maybe had Adam kinsinger
played his cards a little bit smarter
and had a little bit more backbone
politically uh maybe he would have been
able to remain uh
viable in politics but he didn't and his
his district was erased and now he's
pretending to be a martyr when in fact
he's not but it's that first part that
really gets me is there any stupider
word in our current political discourse
than tribalism
yes there is the one the one stupider
word is authoritarianism because it
doesn't mean anything because ever both
sides accuse one another of being
authoritarian and by that they mean
seeking to impose any Vision on politics
which is just what politics is that's
just what self-government is doesn't
mean anything you you think we should
live according to the laws that you and
your community believe in how
authoritarian is just what
that's just called politics that's just
called self-government so that might be
the one word that's slightly Dumber but
the the second dumbest word is tribalism
it's all this tribalism what do you
think politics is
do you think politics
this actually is probably why these
people have a very skewed political view
politics is a team sport in order to do
anything in politics you have to have
allies and you have to have shared goals
and you have to have a division of labor
and you have to have a strategy and you
go and you work together and you get
something done that's politics politics
means public
it doesn't mean personal it doesn't mean
you just do whatever you want
individually all the time
it is tribal and why are there political
tribes
well largely because people have a
shared view of the world and if you
believe that human life has value
then you're going to oppose abortion
and you're also going to oppose
transiting the kids they don't seem like
they're totally related but they share
basic premises about what human life is
who we are where we come from there are
many more examples of that very often
the political tribes that we are so
quick to decry these days
coherent tribes it makes sense
it makes sense that the Democrats who
have no respect for our Traditions are
happy to Outsource our jobs
destroy our communities
obliterate the family open up our
borders it's in throw away our
sovereignty give it to International
institutions
and make sense
frankly we need more tribalism we need
we need clearer tribalism at least on
the right because you've got good
tribalism on the left
or good I mean you've got effective
tribalism on the left that's why the
left is much more effective at wielding
political power the right needs to do
that a little bit better we're not going
to do it with these you know parading
drama queens like Adam kinzinger who who
do nothing but adore themselves on MSNBC
all the time before we go there was a
clip from an actress that I had never
heard of Tia Mowry
and Tia Mowry just went on some show I
guess it's on I guess it's Hoda and
Jenna it's one of the NBC shows and she
she described this this
self-adoring individual atomized view of
society she exalted divorce as a kind of
a self-love
at the end of the day it's about
self-love and when you start to really
work on yourself love yourself know your
value know your worth and then all of a
sudden there's this Awakening and it's
it's not easy it's a hard journey but at
the end of the day I feel like it is so
so worth it my marriage was a success
yeah I look at it as like a curriculum
when you're in college or high school
right you're learning you're growing
you're evolving you're creating and I
was able to create with Corey some
beautiful amazing children and at the
end of that curriculum and at the end
there's a graduation there's a
celebration and I feel like people look
at when they look at marriage that
success equals longevity but no at the
end of the day it's are they happy
um are they thriving are they growing
and that I feel like that is what is
most important it's not about staying in
some something because however long you
are in that situation that equals
success it's about really again are you
happy because life is really short
all of that is wrong everything she just
said is is not true the measure of
marriage is in fact longevity how do you
have a good marriage you don't get
divorced that's
government there's more to it than that
but that's the basic element and what
liberal modernity does
one of the most pernicious aspects of
liberal modernity is it robs us of an
awareness of the significance of time
what Christian civilization does is it
reminds us of the significance of time
because Christ is Incarnate in a time
and a place and and you can see
salvation take place reading the
journalistic account seeing it happen in
real time life is a process of
sanctification it's there are actual
sacraments that we have in space and
time and then sanctification takes place
over space and time and we're just
keenly aware of that we measure our time
according to the the birth of our savior
right anno domini is the year of Our
Lord
and BC is before Christ and and now the
secularists want to rewrite that and
they say it's the Common Era and before
the Common Era what's the Common Era
guys and we're talking about Christ
right so we're measuring that time and
what liberal modernity does and says no
time doesn't matter you never need to
grow up you never need to do anything
you never really need to grow you never
even when you engage in lifelong what
are supposed to be lifelong commitments
you just graduate and you start from
square one again and we never go
anywhere and we never learn anything and
we don't move on and we don't grow up so
we're living in Never Never Land and
it's awful and when you hear this woman
say things like you know I I'm a huge
fan of therapy I love you know it's just
self-love it's just look we're just you
know man it's just kind of about self
you know adulation and me and me and me
and me and there she's using all this
language of the sort of hippie dippy
modern liberal people and it's really
really sad that is not happiness she
says at the end she goes life is short
seize the day and it reminds me of a
quote from G.K Chesterton he says Carpe
Diem you know this idea sees the day the
people who support the Carpe Diem
religion are not the Happy People Carpe
Diem is the religion of very very
unhappy people because they're desperate
they're grasping at anything because
they think that the story is going to
have a sad ending but if you if you
really understand that life is a
marathon not just a Sprint it's not just
about individual moments of pleasure
then you will be much much happier in
the end because then YOLO has a real
meaning it's not just you only live once
so just have some fun and turn to worm
food so you only live once you've got to
make account you've got to build you've
got to grow there is an end in sight you
could go to the good place you could go
to the bad place okay so don't go to the
bad place
let's let's uh let's keep up the fight
let's keep the faith now today's music
Monday
and I am told by my producers that were
listening to rap music today
great the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]